♪
>> Will: I'M WILL CAIN AND I
GUESS CHAOS IN AFGHANISTAN
EMBARRASSMENT ON THE WORLD
STAGE, AMERICANS ENDANGERED,
THIS IS THE PRICE THAT WE PAY.
THIS IS THE COST OF A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THE
AMERICAN POPULATION DOUBTFUL
MANY OF YOU HAVE WATCHING BUT A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THE
AMERICAN POPULATION VOTING FOR
SOMEONE BUT NOT FOR SOMEONE BUT
VOTING AGAINST SOMEONE.
KNOW ONE VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S JUST A FACT.
NO ONE SHOWED UP TO HIS SOCIALLY
DISTANCED ZOOM RALLY.
NO ONE.
NO ONE HAS EVER SAID I LOVE JOE
BIDEN.
THE ENTIRE AMERICAN POPULATION
EITHER VOTED FOR OR AGAINST
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
HELL, NO ONE EVEN VETTED JOE
BIDEN.
AND NOW WE PAY THE PRICE IN THE
FORM OF AN INCOMPETENT, EMPTY
SUIT WHO AND LET'S BE REAL HERE,
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL CONDITION
MAY NOT BE UP TO THE JOB.
NOW, THAT'S NOT TO BE MEAN OR TO
HAVE A HOT TAKE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE IT'S DEARLY COSTING THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IT ALREADY HAS COST US COUNTLESS
TRILLIONS.
IT'S COST US STATURE IN THE
WORLD, CREDIBILITY, AND IT MAY
SOON COST US AMERICAN LIVES.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
AND WE JUST SIMPLY CAN'T BE NICE
ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
EVERY WEEK THIS COUNTRY SEEMS TO
BE SHOVED INTO ANOTHER CRISIS BY
A PRESIDENT WHO DOESN'T SEEM TO
KNOW WHERE HE IS.
AND EVERY TIME HE SAYS THINGS
ARE UNDER CONTROL, YOU CAN BE
REST ASSURED THE EXACT OPPOSITE
IS TRUE.
SO, TODAY, WHEN HE PROMISED THAT
HE IS GOING TO BRING EVERY LAST
AMERICAN, STRANDED IN
AFGHANISTAN HOME, MORE THAN A
LITTLE SKEPTICAL.
AND WHEN HIS PLAN TO GET
AMERICANS SCATTERED THROUGHOUT
AFGHANISTAN BACK TO THE AIRPORT
REVOLVES AROUND TRUSTING THE
TALIBAN, I'M MORE THAN
CONCERNED.
>> WE HAVE NO INDICATION THAT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO GET IN
KABUL THROUGH THE AIRPORT.
WE HAVE MADE AN AGREEMENT WITH
THE TALIBAN THUS FAR.
THEY HAVE ALLOWED THEM TO GO
THROUGH.
IT'S IN THEIR INTEREST FOR THEM
TO GO THROUGH.
SO WE KNOW OF NO CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE
CARRYING AMERICAN PASSPORT ARE
TRYING TO GET THROUGH TO THE
AIRPORT.
>> Will: THAT IS CONTRARY
REPORT.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
THAT IS A LIE.
THE TALIBAN ARE CALLING THE
SHOTS.
NOT JOE BIDEN.
AND GETTING AMERICANS TO THE
AIRPORT ISN'T AS EASY AS THE
PRESIDENT IS CLEARLY LETTING ON
RIGHT THERE.
HERE, FOR EXAMPLE, IS ONE
FIRSTHAND ACCOUNT OF WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON ON THE GROUND
TRYING TO GET TO THE AIRPORT.
>> WHEN WE GOT THERE, THERE WAS
A CROWD OF SEVERAL HUNDRED,
POTENTIALLY EVEN OVER 1,000
INDIVIDUALS, I MEAN, AFGHANS WHO
WERE DESPERATE TO GET INTO THE
AIRPORT, ABLE TO MAKE CONTACT
WITH ONE OF THE MARINES AND
YELLING AMERICAN, AMERICAN,
AMERICANS HERE.
AND HE JUST, YOU KNOW, I MADE
EYE CONTACT WITH HIM AND HE SAID
GET OUT.
BACK NOW.
GET BACK NOW.
AND THE MARINES ARE JUST FIRING,
YOU KNOW, THEIR WEAPONS, YOU
KNOW, FIRING WARNING SHOTS IN
THE AIR.
>> Will: THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
THE TALIBAN SERVING AS USHERS AT
THE AIRPORT, WHICH BY THE WAY,
IS THE ONE PART OF AFGHANISTAN
THAT JOE BIDEN CLAIMS WE HAVE
SECURED AND IT IS TOTALLY
ENGULFED IN CHAOS.
SEE FOR YOURSELF.
[GUNFIRE]
[HORNS BLOWING]
[SCREAMING]
>> Will: THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO IF YOU TAKE JOE
BIDEN'S ADVICE IF YOU CAN MAKE
IT THROUGH THE TALIBAN
CHECKPOINTS WHO APPARENTLY WILL
GLADLY LET AMERICANS THROUGH
WITHOUT HARM.
IGNORE THE REPORTS THAT THEY'RE
GOING HOUSE TO HOUSE, HANGING
PEOPLE WHO HAVE WORKED WITH THE
UNITED STATES.
AND IGNORE THE VIDEO OF THE
TALIBAN MILITANTS BRUTALLY
EXECUTING AN AFGHAN POLICE
CHIEF.
JOE BIDEN SEEMED CONFIDENT IN
HIS SHALL WE CALL IT A PLAN OR
AT LEAST HE WANTS US TO THINK HE
IS CONFIDENT.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE LARGEST,
MOST DIFFICULT AIR LIFT IN
HISTORY AND THE ONLY COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD CAPABLE OF PROJECTING
THIS MUCH POWER ON THE FAR SIDE
OF THE WORLD WITH THIS DEGREE OF
PRECISION IS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> Will: IS THAT WHAT WE ARE
DOING?
WE ARE PROJECTING POWER?
THIS IS POWER?
FRANCE AND BRITAIN ARE GOING IN
KICKING BUTT, DISPATCHING
SPECIAL FORCES TO RESCUE THEIR
CITIZENS AND THIS STARTED LAST
SATURDAY.
WHILE THE PENTAGON PULLED OUR
TROOPS BACK.
MEANWHILE, WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW MANY AMERICANS ARE STRANDED
BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
>> I DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE -- AMERICANS
THAT ARE THERE.
AND THOSE WHO MAY HAVE ALREADY
COME HOME TO THE UNITED STATES.
WE ARE NOT -- WE WANT TO GET A
STRONG NUMBER AS TO EXACTLY HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE THERE, HOW MANY
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND WHERE
THEY'RE.
>> Will: DOES THAT INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE FOR ANYONE?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
AMERICAN MILITARY, OUR ALLIES,
OUR ADVERSARIES?
PRESIDENTS AND PRESIDENCIES ARE
DEFINED BY HOW THEY RESPOND TO A
CRISIS.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE, WHAT WE ARE
WATCHING IS, THIS IS A CRISIS
CREATED BY A PRESIDENT.
AND ADD IT TO THE GROWING LIST
OF CRISES FACILITATED BY
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
THE BORDER DISASTER.
INFLATION, A NATIONWIDE CRIME
SPIKE, THESE ARE NOT CRISES THAT
HE INHERITED.
THESE ARE CRISES THAT HE HAS
CREATED.
NOW, MANY AMERICANS, I THINK,
ARE RIGHTLY ASKING THEMSELVES IF
JOE BIDEN IS PHYSICALLY AND
MENTALLY UP FOR THE JOB.
BUT, THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE REAL
QUESTION.
THE REAL QUESTION MIGHT JUST BE
IS